Let's look at a solution
to our TLB size quiz.
We have a cache that is 32 kB in
size and has a 64 B block size.
We have a 4 kB page size.
So the question is how many TLB entries
do we need to have a similar hit rate
and miss rate to our cache.
Well, if the processor is just
accessing up to 32 kB of memory,
then our TLB needs to cover the same
amount of memory that the cache does,
and that means we need eight pages.
Now it looks like this
would be the best answer.
However, if the processor is not
accessing all of the data in each of
the pages, then we would need more pages
to cover the same amount of memory
because in the cache with
a 64 B block size, we
can fit 512 different blocks, and they
can be spread around the whole memory.
In contrast,
with eight entries in the TLB, we can
only be accessing eight different pages,
while these 500 blocks theoretically
could be in 512 different pages.
So our TLB, in this case, needs to
have up to 512 different pages in
order to have hits for
the same data that the cache does.
In reality,
the number of pages we need for
the same hit rate will be
somewhere in between these two.
So this is the best answer.